uh in the northern hemisphere we're in
the midst of winter and people think of
winter as being dull and drab and dreary
and cold depending on your latitude on
Earth and I I don't think about it that
way because every day of winter has
slightly more sunlight than the day
before it so winter the winter months
are if you date it from the winter
solstice December 21st uh each day shows
more and more sunlight
and so for me that's hopeful it's
summertime where you're systematically
losing sunlight so people say oh we had
the days get longer in the summer and
shorter in the winter the exact opposite
is true if December 21st is the shortest
day of the year first day of winter then
every day after that has to be longer
doesn't it and if June 2st is the
longest day of the year every day into
summer has to be shorter